à 49 ans jean-pierre lagat cet éleveur
de bovins à lisle-sur-tarn une petite
commune à 60 km de toulouse
il est à la tête d'un cheptel d'une
cinquantaine de bêtes et pour les
nourrir sept agriculteurs cultivent du
maïs chaque année à l'automne
il doit se rendre sur ses terres pour y
répandre des engrais sauf que depuis
plusieurs semaines il est confronté à
une situation délicate
ces comités
deux gendarmes dans comment voir si vous
passez au beau milieu de la campagne un
barrage de gendarmes ils filtrent les
allées et venues sur ce chemin de terre
d'habitude désert
bonjour
je suis le propriétaire des terres
est-ce qu'on peut venir mettre de fumier
la gare ça
oui
c'est les 5 hectares un piano
aujourd'hui l'agriculteur a obtenu un
laissez passer
mais très souvent il doit rebrousser
chemin car à quelques centaines de
mètres de là ce petit coin de campagne
est le théâtre d'une véritable guérilla
au sol une cinquantaine de gendarmes en
tenue militaire
dans le ciel un hélicoptère sillonnent
la zone
et face à ces forces de l'ordre des
activistes écologistes prêts à en
découdre
depuis un an ils s'opposent corps et âme
à la construction du barrage de sivens
un chantier d'envergure pour détourner
une rivière et créer un lac artificiel
l'objectif irriguer les terres agricoles
dans cette région où la sécheresse sévit
chaque été un moyen de survivre pour les
agriculteurs un désastre pour les
écologistes
aujourd'hui entre pro et anti barrages
la guerre fait rage les affrontements
sont quotidiens et les forces de l'ordre
ont élu domicile dans ce petit coin du
tarn partisans ou opposants au chantier
qui sortira gagnant de ce conflit
pourquoi ces militants sont prêtes à
tout pour empêcher des travaux enquête
sur le barrage de la discorde
dans la petite ville voisine à gaillac
on ne parle que de ça la construction du
barrage anime toutes les conversations
mais l'impression générale c'est un
certain ras-le-bol
nous fait un sketch depuis trois mois
pour ça suffit à les déplacer les
gendarmes et les compagnies là alors que
j'ai autre chose à faire
chaque rebondissement de la sphère est
largement commentée mais pour les treize
mille habitants le conflit a assez duré
c'est très local quoi c'est vraiment ici
quoi donc du coup maintenant tout le
monde prend un peu position pour ou
contre mais c'est rare que les gens se
rassurent notre quoi et puis surtout
maintenant déjà on peut voir que ça dure
quoi et pourtant l'histoire est loin
d'être terminée voici le campement des
anti barrage leurs occupations et
illégale
le terrain appartient au département ils
sont pourtant une fontaine à livre ici
lutter jour pour occuper sans relâche ce
qu'ils ont baptisé la zone à défendre
certains sont des militants aguerris et
viennent des quatre coins de la france
d'autres ont grandi dans la région
c'est le cas de ben left et l'un des
porte-parole des écologistes il a plus
de vingt ans de militantisme à son actif
notamment chez greenpeace
et pour lui le barrage est une
catastrophe écologique
la voyez là c'est le tescou la rivière
qui était m'inquiéter magnifique avec
ses vieux armes de chaque côté beaucoup
d'ombré beaucoup de fraîcheur pour la
rivière en 2015 ce champ de friches va
laisser place à un lac artificiel d'un
million et demi de mètres cubes
voici le futur aménagement une digue
doit détourner la rivière et créer un
réservoir d'eau pour l'agriculture
locale
un barrage déclaré d'intérêt général par
le département du tarn
mais problème ce terrain est ce que l'on
appelle une zone humide
en clair un milieux marécageux favorable
au développement de la biodiversité les
espèces protégées
ils sont très nombreuses
en plus de 300 plants 94 espèce protégée
animal
ça fait trois ans qu'on se bat pour
essayer d'expliquer qu' il n'y a pas
besoin de faire ça qui a pas besoin de
raser cette cette zone humide qu on
économiserait de l'argent si on était
plutôt les agriculteurs à économiser
l'eau ça c'est ce qu'on faisait
20e siècle quoi c'est vraiment une
politique complètement dépassée de
continuer à faire des barrages pour
l'irrigation
mais ce barrage les agriculteurs le
réclame depuis 30 ans jean-pierre
l'éleveur de bovins en a besoin pour
assurer sa culture de maïs
l'alimentation principale de ses vaches
j'ai une culture qui demande beaucoup de
soleil et beaucoup d'eau le barrage nous
apporterait davantage de la sécurité en
tant que pur pour arroser les maïs et
assurer notre compte
voilà c c'est quelque chose qui qui
serait bénéfique pour les agriculteurs
du secteur les années de sécheresse
jean pierre est obligé d'acheter des
compléments alimentaires pour nourrir
ses bêtes
un surcoût de plusieurs centaines
d'euros pour cet agriculteur qui ne se
verse même pas de salaire cela
représente une somme importante
alors forcément il a du mal à comprendre
les arguments de ses opposants quant aux
pèlerins qu'on ne peut pas maîtriser et
qu'on laisse depuis plus d'un mois ou
deux mois sur le terrain a merdé tout le
monde
voilà c'est c'est quelque chose vivante
missive au moment donné c'est vrai que
il y a des envies qui quitte une quine
ou d'émail je vaux nous battre je sais
pas peut-être ça pourrait venir entre
les deux camps l'incompréhension est
totale et sur le terrain la guerre
continue
le premier à en faire les frais c'est
philippe garnier le directeur du
chantier
tous les jours il doit faire face aux
attaques des échos guerrier là on voit
un morceau d'arbres qui brûlent qui a
été amené par les opposants cette nuit a
donc toute la nuit à des des matériaux
qui sont amenés qui sont mis en travers
on pouvait apercevoir derrière aussi des
barrières qui ont été endommagés par les
opposants on alterne des périodes comme
tout de suite où c'est très calme avec
des périodes où il ya une quinzaine une
vingtaine de personnes qui arrivent d'un
coup et qui projette des choses sur les
gens sur les matériels il ya des
bûcherons qui ont été saisies qui ont
été molestés face à ces menaces philippe
garnier a dû s'adapter
il a transformé son chantier en
véritable forteresse
ça ressemble à un terrain militaire avec
avec des choses simples à la tranchée
pour éviter qu on arrive à passer et
puis des talus un peu partout un portail
un peu renforcé le premier portail était
cassé la première nuit
donc on a deux ceintures de fossés qui
nous protège et qui permettent de
maintenir les opposants un peu loin et
on espère de nous mettre à l'abri de
jets de projectiles qui pourrait abîmer
le matériel depuis quelques semaines le
conflit ne se joue pas seulement sur le
chantier aux alentours certains
agriculteurs se retrouvent malgré eux
plongé dans la tourmente savoir les
petits lots sera à 500 mètres des
travaux mathieu de pierrepont il n'a pas
besoin d'eau pour son activité mais il
est solidaire de ses collègues paysans
mathieu élèves défaisant pour la chasse
c'est déjà nature environnement
dix semaines il ya un mois au petit
matin
l'éleveur a une très mauvaise surprise
l'un de ces enclos a été vandalisé près
de mille oiseaux on en profité pour
s'échapper
montant du préjudice plus de 8000 euros
et deux jours plus tard à peine remis de
ses émotions
mathieu surprend les casseurs en pleine
action
ce sont les anti barrages quand nous
sommes arrivés il y avait trois
personnes qui étaient en train de casser
ce cadre là ici alors il est en train de
casser le cadre a donc on leur a dit de
ne pas bouger un peu les gendarmes et
ils ont coincé à nous bousculer une rixe
a éclaté
on leur a montré qu il est si varié mais
aujourd'hui la tension n'est toujours
pas redescendue alors que nous sommes en
pleine interview un militant anti
barrages nous interpelle face à lui
mathieu reste sur ses gardes
vous en pensez quoi vous qui assure être
en passe de devenir opaque et donc fait
certaines de chez vous entre les deux
hommes l'échangé glacial c'est un
dialogue de sourds le militant repart
aussitôt
mais pour mathieu sa présence n'est pas
un hasard
et elle ravive les inquiétudes c'est sûr
que ça va repartir on sait qu'on l'a 13
rose quelques minutes plus tard la
voiture blanche fait de nouveau son
apparition près des volières
aujourd'hui notre cette fois
l'agriculteur craint le pire
la maison parce que personne
pris de panique il est persuadé qu'il
s'agit d'une nouvelle attaque
finalement la voiture passe son chemin
aujourd'hui plus de peur que de mal mais
pour ce paysan à fleur de peau la simple
présence des antilles barrage est
désormais vécu comme une provocation et
la crainte est partagée par les deux
camps bonjour bonjour
ben le leader des écologistes craint lui
aussi pour sa sécurité il y a quelques
semaines lors d'une manifestation
il a été pris à partie par un militant
pro barrage un échange violent qui lui a
coûté une fracture à la main un grand
baraqué a voulu saisir mon téléphone et
j'ai pas scier téléphone à ma main
gauche et il m'a saisi le petit doigt il
l'a retourné ce qui a cassé l'os là ici
et il m'a maintenu comme ça pendant 30
secondes à peu près en me tenant par le
col en menaçant de
de me jeter sous les sous les roues des
camions qui est passé de l'autre source
est en disant tu es qu un fouteur de
merde jeu de balancier sous les roues je
te descendent je te descendent benz on
tirera grâce à l'intervention des
gendarmes
il a porté plainte mais pour le moment
l'auteur des violences n'a pas été
inquiété ce jour là les forces de
l'ordre ont décidé de reprendre une
partie de la zone pour laisser la place
aux engins de chantier mais les
militants écolos ont la ferme intention
de garder leurs positions
[Musique]
munis de leur caméra il filme toutes les
interventions dans l'espoir
d'enregistrer un faux pas
ici un gendarmes tentent de déloger
trois anti barrages retranché dans une
caravane
écoutez dans la main du militaire une
grenade assourdissante
le gendarme pose un ultimatum aux
écologistes
mais face à leur obstination il n'hésite
pas lors de l'explosion
cette jeune fille a été touchée à la
main elle est aussitôt prise en charge
par les pompiers
de leur côté les gendarmes sont la cible
de cocktails molotov et parfois même de
bombes à l'acide chlorhydrique
ils comptent dans leurs rangs sept
blessés depuis le début du conflit
cette fois les forces de l'ordre sont
venus accompagnés d'un huissier en vertu
d'une décision de justice
il va procéder à l'expulsion d'une
partie du camp vous évacuez la caravane
où je la fais évacuer
je vois qu'il n'ya pas les roues donc je
pense qu'il n'y a pas le choix elle sera
évacuée
désormais les militants n'ont plus
d'échappatoire mais pas question de
quitter les lieux dans le calme ils
veulent crier leur colère
non messieurs sap et rooney
la 500 un dernier acte de résistance
vouée à l'échec face aux forces de
l'ordre
les écologistes capitule mais pour eux
la guerre n'est pas terminée
ils ont promis de revenir